[Music]
with the nation's vaccine roll out well
underway the european union says travel
could be possible during the summer
this weekend the president of the
european commission announced vaccinated
americans can
travel to and within europe kate houston
is live from mccarran airport tonight in
fact terminal 3 where international
flights generally operate kate
yes well it is definitely quiet here at
mccarran's international terminal but it
could look different here
just a few months from now now some of
the travelers i spoke to
are excited by this news saying
requiring vaccinations
is a step in the right direction it's
been more than a year since
non-essential international travel was
shut down due to covet 19.
this not only canceled long planned
vacations but necessary business for
companies
i was vaccinated very early on and
we do i do a lot of international travel
so so that's been important to me royal
marty is the ceo of the henderson-based
biochemical manufacturing company
substrata
while he's been able to develop a new
client overseas during the pandemic
traveling is the next step one of the
biggest things has been usually going
and visiting them and meeting with them
and that hasn't been able to happen and
so
with with the vaccine coming out and
then
more countries starting to open back up
that's been a big thing for us
for lifelong traveler barry shulman
hearing this announcement and knowing
vaccines are required is
great news i think it's wonderful the
two go absolutely hand in hand because
or to put another way if they're not
taking steps and they reopen i wouldn't
be going
shulman has been traveling to europe for
the past 50 years
this year he went a different route and
planned a trip closer to home
saving his world cruise for next year
saying the situation overseas was still
too uncertain
is it safe and what's open and what can
you see and all that
so maybe it's a different experience the
european union represents 27 different
countries much of which are still
under the very high covet 19 risk
assessment level by the cdc
at this time there's no specific time
frame for when americans could go
or how they would prove they received
the vaccine
it's important to note this announcement
is still in the beginning stages
mccarran airport representatives say it
will take some time
to resume international travel to and
from
las vegas reporting live tonight from
mccarran international airport kate
houston 8 news now
kate thank you